TRISHA INGRAM: All right.
Welcome, everyone.
My name is Trisha Ingram.
And I want to welcome all of you
to a very special edition
of Artists at Google.
Today is Take Your Children
to Work Day.
And we are so lucky
to have over 100
Googler kids in our audience.
Are you here, kids?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
TRISHA INGRAM: All right.
Excellent.
As the late, great children's
book author, Roald Dahl, said,
"Those who don't believe in
magic will never see it."
Well, in 2011, nine-year-old
Caine Monroy spent his summer
vacation building an elaborate,
DIY cardboard
arcade inside his dad's used
auto parts store, and invited
people to play.
The entire summer went by.
And Caine had yet to have
a single customer.
Until one day, a filmmaker named
Nirvan stopped by to buy
a door handle.
What happened next inspired
Nirvan's short film.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-My name is Caine.
And I'm nine years old.
My arcade is called
Caine's Arcade.
I'm open on weekends only.
And it's real cheap.
-Caine does not pass by an
arcade without stopping in.
He loves tickets,
playing games.
He loves prizes.
So it was only natural for him
to build his own arcade.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
TRISHA INGRAM: So who here
believes in magic?
Can I see some hands?
That's what I thought.
So Nirvan posted this film on
the internet on April 9, 2012.
And five days later, the
movie went viral.
With now over 8 million views
and screenings around the
world on television and
at festivals, it
has launched a movement.
Here to talk about this
incredible journey is Nirvan
Mullick and Caine Monroy.
Please join me in giving
a warm Google welcome.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
NIRVAN MULLICK: Hello.
Thanks for having us.
I'm Nirvan.
CAINE MONROY: Caine Monroy.
NIRVAN MULLICK: This video
came out about a
little over a year ago.
As Tricia said, it
was April 9.
I just want to share a little
bit of the impact that the
film has had both been on my
life, and Caine's life, and
then we'll do a little
Q and A. Sound cool?
So if you guys have questions,
think about them, and then ask
us at the end.
Literally, the day I posted the
film, it just went viral.
At the end of the film, there
was that little website.
Cainesarcade.com.
It said, donate to Caine's
scholarship fund.
The goals was to
raise a $25,000
scholarship fund for Caine.
Caine's dad, who is in
the back somewhere,
he was like, yeah.
Maybe.
Good luck.
There's George.
So the first day we posted the
film, it got over a million
views, and it raised over
$60,000 on day one.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
NIRVAN MULLICK: That
was the thought.
We raised the goal, actually,
to $100,000, thinking by the
time Caine's ready for college,
this might even cover
a semester, because tuition
is going up so fast.
So we raised the goal
to $100,000.
And the next day, it raised
over $110,000.
At that point, we were
like, should we
raise the goal again?
And George is like, yes.
Raise it to a million
bucks, please.
We said, no, wait.
We don't really know what's
going on here.
We need to kind of figure out
what's happening, have a plan
before we invite the global
community that's helped us
reach this goal without
having a plan.
Because the first two days, I
mean we were getting phone
calls, and the media
was calling us.
I didn't sleep for the
first two days.
We were going and doing
all these talk shows.
Remember?
CAINE MONROY: Yes.
Paris.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Well, not in the
first two days, we didn't
go to Paris.
But we did end up
going to Paris.
So there's this huge,
global interest.
By the end of the fifth
day, we'd raised over
$152,000 for Caine.
We gave him this giant,
cardboard check at his arcade.
But it wasn't just the money
that was being raised.
There was media around
the world.
Justin Timberlake was
tweeting it out.
It was trending on Twitter
worldwide.
It had over 140 million media
impressions in the first week.
And the more magical thing
was the response from
kids around the world.
Kids and educators saw the film,
and they just started
making things.
So this is a little clip from
a follow-up film I made,
showing a little bit of the
global response from kids and
people around the world
to Caine's Arcade.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Finally tonight,
we have a great
story out of Los Angeles.
East LA, to be precise.
-When you're a lonely,
nine-year-old boy, an empty
cardboard box can be a universe
of possibilities.
-I found this great story.
I want to share it with you.
-They're lining up to play
at his cardboard arcade.
-This kid made his own arcade.
-And the internet has been
flooded with response videos.
-Yeah!
You get ten tries.
-50.
-Caine, this is me,
Jojo Romand.
-I made this pinball machine.
-It's called Tilt-a-Ball.
-Nice!
-Awesome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
NIRVAN MULLICK: So there's this
beautiful response from
kids around the world.
Something magical was
really happening.
After two days of not sleeping,
I had this idea of
trying to start a foundation,
and have an impact on more
kids like Caine, who just needed
a high five and their
creativity to be fostered.
Are you going for the mic?
What?
You're four?
Wow.
I'm 38.
[LAUGHTER]
NIRVAN MULLICK: So I stayed up
for two days, and then I wrote
this mission statement on a
napkin to find, foster, and
fund creativity and
entrepreneurship in more kids
like Caine.
Because it was just clear there
are so many kids like
Caine out there.
Parents were posting pictures of
their kids on Facebook, on
our Facebook page, saying,
my daughter is four,
and she saw the movie.
She just built an arcade
in our kitchen.
She's got her own shirt.
How do we get some customers
into the kitchen?
So the idea was to try make a
foundation that would help
foster creativity in
kids everywhere.
So I had a conversation
with the Goldhirsh
Foundation Ben Goldhirsh.
They started "GOOD Magazine."
Really great folks.
I've known them for 12 years.
He said to me, you guys are
starting at the destination.
There's so many organizations
trying to figure out how to
scale things like project-based
learning.
What can we do to support you?
At that point, they offered us a
quarter million dollar grant
to start up the Imagination
Foundation.
The quarter million dollar grant
started matching, dollar
for dollar, the donations being
made by the public to
the Caine Scholarship Fund.
So every dollar given by the
public to Caine Scholarship
Fund, the Goldhirsh Foundation
gave us $1.00 to start up
Imagination Foundation.
At that point, we raised the
goal on the website from
$100,000 to $25,000.
And this is a little bit of what
we accomplished in the
first five months from the
film being posted.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So the Imagination Foundation's
mission is to
find, foster, and fund
creativity and
entrepreneurship in
kids like Caine.
After we started the foundation,
the first thing we
did is we hit the ground
running with a
school pilot program.
Within the first two months,
over 100 schools in nine
countries participated, using
project-based learning to
teach kids math, science,
and engineering.
-One of the greatest challenges
I think we face in
education is tapping into
children's natural powers of
creativity.
And one of the appeals of
Caine's Arcade is it's
demonstrated how deep those
powers are, and how readily
people will rise to
the challenge if
you give it to them.
-So we decided to give
this world a
global Cardboard Challenge.
We Invited people around the
world to build anything
awesome out of cardboard,
recycled materials, and their
imagination.
And three weeks after posting
this challenge, we had over
271 events organized in 41
countries around the world.
-I told Caine that when
I was a kid, I also
built cardboard rockets.
These were space capsules
that we could
actually fly in our backyard.
And here I am, many years later,
and I'm still building
spacecraft.
But this one, a real once
that landed on Mars.
-Childhood imagination will
take you from cardboard to
this in just a few years.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
NIRVAN MULLICK: The Cardboard
Challenge culminated in a
global day of play, which last
year, happened on October 6,
which was the one-year
anniversary of the flash mob
we did for Caine.
And this year, it will be
happening again on October 5.
So every year on the anniversary
of the flash mob,
we invite the world to come out
and play, and celebrate
the creativity of kids
om their community.
This year, the goal of
Imagination Foundation is to
engage one million kids in 70
countries in creative play.
We've been growing a
lot, very quickly.
So we invite you all to find
out more, and maybe
participate in a Cardboard
Challenge in your communities.
And I just want to share a
little bit about how this has
impacted Caine, right?
You remember that day, the flash
mob, before the film
went all viral.
CAINE MONROY: Yes.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Do you remember
what you said to you
dad when you guys were
driving home?
CAINE MONROY: It was the
best day of my life.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Yeah.
So George told me that the next
day, and it kind of made
me tear up.
The impact it had.
I mean, we've raised over
$232,000 now for Caine's
Scholarship Fund.
This is a photo from
the Saturday after
the film went viral.
We didn't invite people this
time to a flash mob.
But over 1,000 people just
showed up spontaneously to
play Caine's Arcade.
And we had, like, there was
a line around the block.
There was like a four
or five hour wait.
And Caine actually started
selling a $20 Fast Fun Pass,
where you can skip the line.
[LAUGHTER]
NIRVAN MULLICK: Caine was the
youngest ever entrepreneur to
speak at the USC Marshall
School of Business.
CNN came out, and filmed
you there?
CAINE MONROY: Yes.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Then Caine
went up to Sacramento.
And he was given the Latino
Spirit Award at the California
State Assembly.
And he wore sneaks
with his suit.
We went to France, as
Caine mentioned.
Caine was the youngest ever
speaker at the Cannes Lions
International Festival of
Creativity, which we renamed
Caine's Lions, for the day.
[LAUGHTER]
NIRVAN MULLICK: He was just
out in New York, where he
spoke at a Tedx Teen event,
hosted by Chelsea Clinton.
Was that fun?
CAINE MONROY: Yeah.
NIRVAN MULLICK: That
was your first
time on stage by yourself.
CAINE MONROY: Yeah.
NIRVAN MULLICK: I love
this picture.
This is Caine backstage,
making games out of the
pamphlets that they had.
He did the same thing when
we were in Paris.
This is a photo from--
this was Caine's Arcade for
the Day of Play last year,
right across the street.
We had to expand for the day.
We had over 800 folks
come out and play.
Kids brought their
arcade games.
Made new arcade games.
Caine added the mayor
to his staff.
And he got a cardboard key to
the city, which was superfine.
He got a billboard, too, which
was always one of his things
he asked his dad.
Like, can I get a billboard
to start my arcade?
And his dad was like before,
it's a little
bit out of the budget.
But people still come out to
play Caine's Arcade from all
over the world.
How many customers do you
get when you open up?
CAINE MONROY: Around
50 through 100.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Wow.
It's been a year and a half
since the flash mob, a year
since the film came out.
When we went to Paris together,
Caine was like
finding cardboard tubes
in the alley.
Just nonstop playing.
On the way back, on the flight
back, I wanted to know.
I was like, curiously,
Caine, what have you
learned from all this?
What have you learned?
So I asked him to write down a
few things that he learned.
But we didn't have any paper.
So he wrote down these
five lessons with the
Air France barf bag.
So these are "Caine's 5 Lessons
on a Barf Bag." Will
you read them out
for us, Caine?
CAINE MONROY: [INAUDIBLE]?
NIRVAN MULLICK: This is "What
Did Caine Learn?"
CAINE MONROY: "Be nice
to customers.
Do a business that is fun.
Do not give up.
Start with what you have.
Use recycled stuff."
NIRVAN MULLICK: Pretty
awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
NIRVAN MULLICK: First thing, I
love that he circled, "Do not
give up," with a squiggly
circle, and underlined it
three times.
I think that's my
motto as well.
This has become my business
plan for the Imagination
Foundation.
I've learned a lot,
too, from this.
It's been a life-changing
year for both of us.
The first thing I learned is it
doesn't take much to change
the life of a child.
Sometimes just giving a kid a
high five at just the right
moment, or stopping to play.
Also, the next time you go buy
a door handle, you never know
what's going to happen.
The smallest moments
can sometimes
have the biggest impact.
And finally, it was always
buy the Fun Pass.
That was a fun moment.
So that's our little
slides, and talks.
And we invite you all to play,
through Caine's Arcade and the
Imagination Foundation, In our
next Cardboard Challenge.
You guys can go and see ways
to bring this to your
community, and help us reach a
million kids in 70 countries
with creative play.
Oh, and if you have
any questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What did you spend
your $20,000 on?
CAINE MONROY: It's
for college.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
NIRVAN MULLICK: The question
was, what has Caine spent his
money on that he's made?
But you made a fair amount
selling Fun Passes at your
arcade and stuff, right?
CAINE MONROY: Yes.
NIRVAN MULLICK: What do
you spend all that on?
CAINE MONROY: Prizes.
NIRVAN MULLICK: For
the arcade?
Like investing back
in the business?
CAINE MONROY: Yes.
NIRVAN MULLICK: But not
just in your business.
Like you've been able
to buy a few things
for fun, too, right?
CAINE MONROY: Yes.
NIRVAN MULLICK: What kind
of stuff do you buy?
CAINE MONROY: Nerf guns.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Nerf guns.
[LAUGHTER]
NIRVAN MULLICK: Caine also
saved up for his first
go-kart, His first car.
So he bought a go-kart.
Your dad says you buy
a lot of LEGOs too.
CAINE MONROY: Yes.
So LEGOs, Nerf gun,
and go-kart.
Yeah?
You want to ask a question
here on the mic?
AUDIENCE: No, it's
not a question.
It's something that
I [INAUDIBLE].
NIRVAN MULLICK: Well, go
ahead and tell us.
AUDIENCE: I might go
to Caine's Arcade.
NIRVAN MULLICK: That
would be awesome.
AUDIENCE: I hope I can.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Yeah.
Caine, you want to let
people know when
you're open and stuff?
CAINE MONROY: This Saturday,
I am going to be open.
NIRVAN MULLICK: What
are your hours?
CAINE MONROY: Let's
see, 9:00 to 3:00.
NIRVAN MULLICK: 9:00 to 3:00.
Caine sets his own schedule.
And I post it on the
facebook/cainesaracade page.
We pin the hours on the top.
He's not always there.
I actually asked his dad
recently, like how does Caine
set his hours?
And he was like, Caine
has a wallet now.
And when his wallet is
empty, that's when
we open up the arcade.
[LAUGHTER]
NIRVAN MULLICK: But he's also in
school during the week, and
stuff, so we have irregular
hours still.
Who had the next question?
I saw somebody.
You?
Hi?
AUDIENCE: What time
do you open?
CAINE MONROY: 9:00 o'clock.
NIRVAN MULLICK: 9:00 am.
Sometimes 10:00 am.
George, do you want
to come up, too?
Everybody, George Monroy,
Caine's dad.
Come on up, George.
Come on.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: How did you
get the idea of
making a cardboard arcade?
CAINE MONROY: I wanted to
have my own arcade.
AUDIENCE: What?
CAINE MONROY: I always wanted
to own my own arcade.
I just built one out
of cardboard.
Cheaper.
AUDIENCE: Well, where's
your store?
CAINE MONROY: Boyle Heights.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Do you guys know
where Boyle Heights is?
AUDIENCE: No.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Well, you can
actually google Caine's
Arcade, and it will come up.
You can see it on
Google Earth.
And you can go down
to Street View.
And you can actually see a
photo of Caine before the
movie came out.
He's sitting there waiting for
customers on the Google Earth
AUDIENCE: Do you like
your arcade?
CAINE MONROY: Yes, very much.
AUDIENCE: Where did you
get all the cardboard?
CAINE MONROY: From my dad's
auto parts shop.
They get from parts.
AUDIENCE: How much money
do you earn each day?
NIRVAN MULLICK: Don't
tell him.
CAINE MONROY: Like $100.
AUDIENCE: Do you plan to
expand the arcade?
CAINE MONROY: Maybe.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Caine's built a
couple new games since then.
My favorite, I actually made
a little movie about.
It's called Ticket Grab.
Where a neighbor was throwing
out a refrigerator box.
Can you tell them a little
bit about Ticket Grab?
How that works?
CAINE MONROY: Oh, I guess our
neighbor was getting a new
refrigerator.
So they threw the box outside,
and I just got it to use it
for Ticket Grab.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Yeah, but
Ticket Grab was kind of
elaborate, right?
CAINE MONROY: Yes.
NIRVAN MULLICK: What did you buy
to make Ticket Grab work?
CAINE MONROY: A leaf
blower, and tape.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Yeah.
Caine made a ticket grab
out of this cardboard
refrigerator box.
And he's got a leaf blower
that he bought.
He's got all these little
prize tickets.
And he puts them inside.
Then you go inside the box, and
he turns it on outside.
And tickets swirl around.
He made a clear, little portal
door so you can see inside.
He also made an emergency
exit.
At the top where you
have to pull, he
wrote these rules down.
The rules are like, scream,
yell, and have fun.
The emergency exit was after
we'd gone to France, from the
safety descriptions.
He's been incorporating
a lot of his travels.
Pretty cool.
AUDIENCE: Caine, what
do you want to study
when you grow up?
CAINE MONROY: Engineer.
AUDIENCE: All right.
[CHUCKLES AND APPLAUSE]
NIRVAN MULLICK: Good answer
for this crowd, Caine.
AUDIENCE: Could you tell
me some tips of
how to get the arcade?
CAINE MONROY: Believe
in yourself.
Don't stop.
AUDIENCE: What's your favorite
game that you made?
CAINE MONROY: That
claw machine.
It has a string on a hook, and
it has teddy bears inside.
You try to hook it, and bring
it through the hole.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Caine has
started building these on
commission, so you can talk to
him, and he can make you a--
He's made a couple cardboard
claw machines.
I bought one.
The Exploratorium in San
Francisco bought the original
claw machine.
They have in their permanent
collection.
AUDIENCE: What's your newest
game that you've made?
CAINE MONROY: Made?
I think it's a soccer one.
NIRVAN MULLICK: He's made some
games since then that aren't
even in the movie.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Yeah.
CAINE MONROY: Air hockey.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
NIRVAN MULLICK: You want to
describe how an air hockey
game works?
CAINE MONROY: Air
hockey works--
there's like this really
soft paper that
I use that's slippery.
Then I just got a cardboard,
little like cardboard circle.
Then I make two things,
like you hit it.
Then I made a hole.
It goes down, then you get it
back, and keep on playing.
NIRVAN MULLICK: There you go.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
NIRVAN MULLICK: Can
you translate
that question at all?
AUDIENCE: I'm scared.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Well,
thank you for that.
I love that question.
It might be my favorite
question.
GEORGE MONROY: Caine's Arcade.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Caine's
Arcade.
CAINE MONROY: I said
thank you.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Does anybody
else have any questions?
AUDIENCE: What do you want to do
for a living after college?
NIRVAN MULLICK: What you
want to do for a
living after college?
CAINE MONROY: Own
my own arcade.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Keep
the arcade going.
Caine is still figuring
it out.
Like you've said sometimes,
maybe a game designer.
CAINE MONROY: Yeah.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Who was your
first customer?
CAINE MONROY: Nirvan.
NIRVAN MULLICK: That's me.
AUDIENCE: What did you
go there to buy?
Play?
NIRVAN MULLICK: I went there
to buy a door handle for my
'96 Corolla, a car.
It had a broken door handle.
I'd never been there before.
And it was the only used auto
parts store on the block that
had a little swing hanging
from the tree.
So I stopped there.
And then I met Caine.
CAINE MONROY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Did he have
a door handle?
NIRVAN MULLICK: Yes, I bought
the door handle.
[LAUGHTER]
NIRVAN MULLICK: George later
actually put it in
for free for me.
GEORGE MONROY: It was the
least I could do.
NIRVAN MULLICK: It's my
magic door handle.
AUDIENCE: How did
you feel after--
CAINE MONROY: The flash mob?
AUDIENCE: What?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CAINE MONROY: It felt pretty
cool, like everybody came.
AUDIENCE: Are you going
to make another one?
CAINE MONROY: Arcade?
Maybe.
AUDIENCE: How much does
a ticket for--
CAINE MONROY: Fun Pass?
AUDIENCE: A Fun Pass and
a four-try game, thing?
CAINE MONROY: The Fun
Pass costs $2.00.
Then the four-try, we
don't have anymore.
NIRVAN MULLICK: You don't
have it anymore?
CAINE MONROY: It's
just one turn.
NIRVAN MULLICK: So if somebody
gave you $1--
CAINE MONROY: No.
NIRVAN MULLICK: They
can't play?
Nobody has ever not bought the
Fun Pass, that I know of.
It's a really good upsell.
AUDIENCE: How much does
one turn cost?
CAINE MONROY: One turn costs?
You got to get a Fun Pass.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
NIRVAN MULLICK: But then
you get 500 turns.
AUDIENCE: Could you buy
a Fun Pass right now?
CAINE MONROY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can I buy one?
Not soon.
After.
NIRVAN MULLICK: After this.
And we also have some Caine's
Arcade staff shirts, if you
guys want to join
Caine's staff.
AUDIENCE: How old were you when
you started the arcade?
CAINE MONROY: Like eight.
End of eight.
AUDIENCE: How long did it take
for the flash mob did die out?
CAINE MONROY: The
sun went down.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Caine was
working until what, like how
long, George?
GEORGE MONROY: Until like
8:00 o'clock at night.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Yeah.
Caine worked until 8 o'clock at
night, and then after all
the customers left--
hang on one sec.
AUDIENCE: How many
kids did you get?
NIRVAN MULLICK: How many kids?
Like customers?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NIRVAN MULLICK: How many
customers did you get?
AUDIENCE: Kid customers.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Kid customers.
CAINE MONROY: Like 50?
NIRVAN MULLICK: 50 that day?
We have a guest book
there that's full.
You can come, when you come
play, and you can leave a
comment, and draw a picture.
But after the flash mob,
I mean Caine was
there until 8 o'clock.
The last customer.
Then afterwards, he was cleaning
up the gains, putting
the toys away.
I got that last interview with
him that was playing during
the credits kind of after
that had all died down.
Got his first impression
of what it was like.
AUDIENCE: How long did it take
you to build your arcade?
CAINE MONROY: Pretty
much like one year.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Because you guys
see the pile of cardboard
boxes over there?
We're going to have a chance
to build some games.
AUDIENCE: So you were
basically Caine's
best friend, right?
NIRVAN MULLICK: I was not
Caine's best friend.
We didn't know each other.
I went to buy the door handle.
I never met him before.
He asked if I wanted to play,
and I asked how it worked.
And so I bought the Fun Pass.
I have my first Fun Pass with
me, if any of you guys want to
see it afterwards.
I'll be over--
It's right here.
I keep it with me.
And every now and then,
Caine's like, oh,
you're out of turns.
You got to give me another
$2 to keep charging it.
CAINE MONROY: One month.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Yeah.
It expires after a month.
AUDIENCE: When is Caine
going to grow up?
NIRVAN MULLICK: Caine, when
are you going to grow up?
[LAUGHTER]
CAINE MONROY: Let's see.
10 more years?
NIRVAN MULLICK: 10 more years.
CAINE MONROY: I'll
be 20 years old.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Caine wrote an
essay about growing up, when
you turn 10, going
to double digits.
We have it on the cainesarcade
blog.
It's really cute.
AUDIENCE: What's
double digits?
NIRVAN MULLICK: Double digits.
When you turn from nine.
One through nine is single.
Then when he became 10,
he's double digits.
Well, he just wrote down his
reflections on getting older.
AUDIENCE: How do
get the shirts?
CAINE MONROY: I buy them.
NIRVAN MULLICK: George, will you
tell the story when Caine
went to make the shirt in Palm
Springs, and design it?
GEORGE MONROY: We were in the
store for like two hours while
he decided what color
he wanted, what he
wanted it to say.
He wanted to put his
address on it.
And he spelled out 'staff'
because he didn't
know how to say it.
He didn't know what it meant.
He just knew that if you had
it on your shirt, that you
work there.
So he spelled it out
for the lady.
And the lady put it on.
She goes, oh, you want staff?
He goes, yeah, because
I work there.
So then he wanted to put his
address on the back.
And she goes, oh, no, no.
You don't want to put your
address, son, because then
they'll know where you live.
He goes, I want them to
know where I live.
So we ended up not putting
the address.
But as you can see, this shirt
is world famous now.
I think Nirvan sold over
a million copies.
NIRVAN MULLICK: I don't think
we sold a million shirts.
But we do sell shirts
on the website, too.
Caine gets some money from the
shirts, and the foundation
gets some money from
the shirts, too.
Or you can go to his arcade
and get shirts there.
He's got a couple of
different designs.
AUDIENCE: Why doesn't
his shirt say
'manager' or something?
NIRVAN MULLICK: We actually
did make a shirt for Caine
that says 'boss.' So he has a
shirt that says 'boss.' But is
it dirty, or did
you outgrow it?
Or what's going on?
CAINE MONROY: Dirty.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Dirty.
His 'boss' shirt is dirty.
The boss--
AUDIENCE: Where does Caine
want to go to college?
NIRVAN MULLICK: Caine, the
question is, where you want to
go to college?
CAINE MONROY: I don't
know yet.
NIRVAN MULLICK: He
doesn't know.
He's gotten a couple offers.
MIT wants him to go.
USC wants him to go.
UCLA wants him to go.
He still has some time
to figure it out.
TRISHA INGRAM: Thank you, guys,
so much for coming.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Thank
you, guys.
CAINE MONROY: Thank you.
NIRVAN MULLICK: Thanks
for having us.
[APPLAUSE]